and what did you say in response when
misheard said Tell The World Johnny tell
them Johnny Depp I Johnny Depp a man I'm
a victim too of domestic violence
I said yes
um I have nothing further your honor
okay so Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard
is probably the topic that's the most
requested on my Channel right now the
ongoing defamation lawsuit ends up
trending every day and though it's not
the kind of topic I tend to cover I do
think it's important to acknowledge
because there's a lot of things going on
with it the case is tied in so heavily
with death and Amber's career and it
means a lot for the future of not only
the DCU but also several films
surrounding it now I have my own
opinions on the case and it definitely
seems like in the court of public
opinion that Depp is completely
demolishing Hope's team we're pretty
much at the halfway point now and I
really wanted to do more of an
analytical video on why that could be
the main factors leading into it and
what the consequences for either side
could be if the trial goes in their
favor now I have my own opinions on
who's winning but I'm gonna try and keep
them out of this as much as possible as
domestic abuse is a very serious subject
that I don't really want to make the
wrong statement on by dropping an
off-the-cuff Comet with her also being a
figurehead in the metoo movement there's
some really until negative things that
could come from this if she's found
guilty and I don't want to put the
impression in anyone's head that women
shouldn't be taken seriously because of
what the outcome is all accusations of
domestic abuse should be seen as very
serious things so yeah just keeping my
opinion out of this as much as I
possibly can now it will be difficult as
this is something that everyone's going
to have their own perspective on but I
think in a video like this it's
important to keep my personal view to
one side as it can often Cloud the
analysis anyway like many people I was
very much on the side of Amber Heard
when the accusations first came out
these were extremely serious things that
she was lobbying against step and the
images of her bruises and so on
definitely made it look like she was the
sole victim in all of this the metoo
movement then happened and it felt like
a very positive thing that was removing
lots of predators and abuses from high
profile positions so that they couldn't
do it anymore I must admit I wasn't a
massive Johnny Depp fan and though I
liked some of his movies he wasn't
someone whose career I followed all the
time now the papers completely tore him
apart and there was very much a pile on
on the internet to the point it became
difficult for the guy to make a public
appearance without being called a wife
beater I remember when the guy appeared
on stage as Grindelwald during a
fantastic Beast panel and yet it was a
very bad luck due to the accusations
however over time there started to be
people going to his defense including
high-profile celebrities and his
loyalist supporters lots of evidence
came to the Forefront that seemed to
debunk all of Hertz claims and over time
things have kind of swung in the favor
of Johnny with it seeming less and less
likely that he was the only person at
fault now dep and head had a Face-Off in
court in the UK and he ended up losing
it which pretty much meant he had to be
ousted from Fantastic Beasts though
there was lots of evidence that he
supplied showing herd was in fact the
abusive one this verdict very much meant
that Warner Brothers had to let go of
Deb from one of their Flagship
franchises now who had managed to keep
her all in Aquaman even with all the
photos of bruises Deb's injuries and the
recordings a petition starred online to
have her removed from the role and it
currently has millions of signatures on
it but up till now now she's remained in
place now that kind of takes us to the
current case which is now on its ninth
day things have done a complete 180
since the original statement by heard
and it seems like everyone's in-depth
side there's lots of comments that I've
seen asking why Deb has even come to
court after the previous loss I think
when you look at what's happened he has
very little to lose Depp is being
branded a wife beat up and if he loses
he's still gonna be called that this is
at least getting his side of the story
out there because it's rare that men are
taken as seriously as women in domestic
abuse cases on the other side of this if
Amber loses it not only destroys her
career but it potentially exposes her
for what she really is now for this part
of the video I want to firstly discuss
the psychological aspects that are in
effect to show why Deb is clearly more
favorable overheard this boils down to
the legal team's approach and how it
very much mirrors what Depp is accusing
Amber of her Court hearings are very
different in normal arguments and
interactions in real life if someone was
standing around saying you'd done this
and that you'd probably stand up deny it
argue with them and then that would
escalate however in a court people have
to remain silent whilst the person are
against testifies and thus they can't
respond or reply to it because of this
the legal team very much becomes the
voice of their client and it's in this
that it can also leave an impression on
the jury now during the statement by
debenhood's marriage counselor she said
that Johnny didn't really have a voice
in their sessions Amber constantly
talked over the top of him and would
interrupt whenever he said something or
wasn't going her way this is very much
reflected in hertz legal team it's
getting to the point that there's Tick
Tock videos meaning how many objections
and comments Ikea say are said by herd's
lawyers objection calls for hearsay
[Music]
[Music]
he'd had a conversation with Miss hurt
[Music]
let's move beyond the conversation
he said yes they have
[Music]
I'm learning
now what this does is that it reinforces
the idea in the jury a Johnny doesn't
have a voice like the marriage counselor
said Johnny keeps getting interrupted so
her defense doing this makes it seem
like herd also did the same thing now on
the flip side of this Johnny's defense
are quite chilled laid back and for the
most part they let people talk and
answer the questions without
interrupting them so it seems like
Johnny is that way too the jury
subconscious will be affected by this so
that Amber's side it seems like the
aggressive one hell it's even gotten so
bad that herd's lawyers are objecting
their own questions
you didn't know what could cause damage
to Mr death's hand while you were there
on March 8th correct Dr Kepler told me
he sustained an injury on one of his
rejection here's here's a I mean that's
yeah
okay
yikes it's really bad and the other
aspects I think they're failing on is
the fact that going after drug abuse
rather than domestic abuse throughout
the trial they've tried to expose that
Johnny was addicted to drugs and also
alcohol if you do a statement like this
once it can be quite shocking especially
with that being such a big star we
typically tend to think of actors as
Role Models so if used effectively this
can be very very damaging however if you
keep mentioning it it normalizes the
thing so that the shock factor is
removed and what you're left with is US
hearing the same point over and over and
over being addicted to drugs doesn't
mean that you're an abusive person so
it's belaboring the point a bit to
constantly keep bringing this up time
and time again this is made worse by the
fact that the evidence they have for
Johnny being abusive is very very small
and nothing that can be completely
proven the councilor said there was
mention of an open-handed slap during a
therapy session but it's inconsequential
when played next to the recordings of
heard on tape admitting to hang Johnny
let me the drug thing should be the
first step that sets up herds team
leading into the domestic abuse however
when the drugs take the focus you
completely lose the attention on the
domestic side of it and end up just
putting all your eggs in the proverbial
basket of that which doesn't necessarily
give way to any of the accusations so I
think the two main reasons that herd's
team is failing is because they're very
much acting in attack mode but providing
very little behind what they're saying
so they're going off on a certain path
and trying to stop someone from giving
their statement whilst also interrupting
the show they have very little to
actually give reason to why they're
objecting now in recent days some of the
audio played by the lawyers was really
bad and Johnny referred to there being a
bloodbath like there was at the island
Depp wasn't asked questions on this so
he couldn't elaborate which again backs
up the idea that he's not really getting
a voice even though he has been
testifying a lot now context like this
is important and several texts have been
presented by Hood's team between Deb and
Paul Bettany they talk about burning her
doing stuff with her corpse and it looks
really bad however Deb explained that he
has a dark sense of humor and that these
are direct quotes from Monty Python in a
scene about burning a witch it kind of
strips herd's team of them being the
ammo that they initially thought it to
be and there's also the Milani makeup
statement its evidence has been
questioned highly since she made her
statement about Johnny and she's often
regarded as making the whole thing up
and faking attacks for sympathy there
are several instances where she's
apparently been heavily battered but the
next day when she's appeared on TV she's
been absolutely fine during a statement
her lawyers showed a makeup palette I
think I think it's called her palette no
idea anyway they showed a Milani maker
palette and had apparently been in her
purse for their entire relationship they
said it had been what she'd used to
cover up her bruises but Milani put out
a post saying the kit wasn't available
until they'd already broken up kit I
think kit is right so anyway this kind
of shuts down her argument even more and
though the jury might not end up
factoring this into their final thoughts
it is important to bear in mind although
whether the trial ramped up was a very
good strategy by dep's team team and
they brought in recordings where he
talked about possibly taking his own
life this laid the groundwork for how
herd had pushed him to the brink and it
was absolutely devastating to hear they
then topped it up by playing audio clips
of the argument between Depp and hurt
[Music]
absolutely
absolutely amazing
is that what matters
your life
is this what matters to you your party
I never love you
and what we're talking about tonight is
what
they said when I ended up confronting
head and trying to work with her to
confront the media
I don't know how to get my um
verification back
we write a letter together
[Music]
saying that we're going to take this out
of the public eye
saying we've been trying to work this
out on our own
same
but the media has created such a [ __ ]
hateful storm
that it's sickening
that we love each other
and that we want to make sure each other
is okay
how we had fights in the past have we
had this or whatever [ __ ] it they
already know all that [ __ ] don't matter
here's the deal no it matters
that you have no idea every ounce of my
credibility
has been taken from I mean and gun store
is dishonest it's great
you know
the abuse the abuse thing is is is if
we've got to deal with that yeah
of my credit is is my credibility you
know what I don't know why did you put
that out there
I didn't force you to
I promise
everything is
[Music]
forget it you don't believe what I say
you don't believe okay
every step of the way infinite I did not
put this anywhere I didn't let me talk
to the [ __ ] team
the cops you told I only called the cops
you told IO to call the cops
what was happening yeah oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry because the last time that it got
crazy between us I really did think of
coming up with my life and I thought you
would do it on accident
and I told you that
I said oh my God I thought the first
time Amber I I lost a [ __ ] finger man
come on
I had a [ __ ] I had a [ __ ] a
mineral can a drug what kind of mineral
spirits thrown on my nose at this point
I rammed up to what is very much going
to be remembered as the quote that I
think will be what people take from this
trial
s
[Music]
see what the jury judge thinks tell the
world Johnny tell them Johnny Depp I
joined up man I'm I'm a victims and I
know it's a fair fight if these puppy
people believe or besides of you this
then got asked as the final question and
what did you say in response when
misheard said Tell The World Johnny tell
them Johnny Depp I Johnny Depp a man I'm
a victim too of domestic violence
I said yes
um
I have nothing further your honor it's a
massive mic drop and such a major way to
end that statement that it will be the
thing many people remember him for
saying very well planned out and it
completely rocks hurts defense now you
might have noticed externally that the
media have stopped spinning it in a
certain way they used to use quite bad
headlines about death and how he was a
wife be there but now it seems a lot
more balanced now from here I think that
Warner Brothers are left with very
little option of what to do with Amber
unless she's Vindicated in the next
three weeks then they have to get rid of
her don't know how they're gonna do it
just have mirror drown off screen or
something people don't seem to care and
it might be the one thing that finally
unites all of the DC fandom now firing
here they have to do it because they
very much set the standard by firing
Johnny and it'll look like double
standards if they don't get rid of her
they kind of made the rules I think a
lot of anger around this case boils down
to the double standard surrounding the
whole thing so yeah I think it's a
really bad luck and either way they
might get rid of her even if she wins
she's even getting bullied leaving the
chord and the petition against her is
constantly clocking up names Jason Momoa
even followed Johnny Depp on Instagram
recently and with him being the star of
Aquaman it could show how things are
going now I have heard that Warner
Brothers kind of preempted this trial
and that they ended up cutting down
Amber's role by quite a lot they could
even end up recasting before that movie
depending on what the cost and backlash
is and that's pretty much how we view
the trial and why we think it's going a
certain way like I've said we're only
halfway through at the moment so it
could all really change and things like
this can reverse on one piece of
evidence so I wouldn't say it's in the
bag for Johnny we will find out who wins
very soon but in the meantime I want to
hear your comments whether you'd like to
see more coverage and how you think it's
going comment below and let me know and
thanks for checking out the video you
take care peace